don't trust white people I don't trust
white people for a multitude of reasons
but one of the main reasons is they're
unpredictable like I think about all the
times where I really considered white
people my friends and then when we got
in a small argument they released all
the racism they hid throughout our whole
friendship
scary and then I think about the fact
that people
what what does that mean that would be
odd if you were friends with somebody
and then the moment you had a little
tiff over I don't know um hey let's
split the bill no I'll pick up the bill
or you had a little tiff over I want to
go see this movie no I want to go see
that movie they just started saying you
n-word you
your clan hood or something like that
yeah I don't I don't believe that has
ever happened now does she mean that
when she and her white alleged friends
get into an argument the very fact of
disagreeing is taken to be racist
because that's how the libs argue today